hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
and just checking in on
you what's going on how are
you how's it going oh Billy
freckles sitting on his pasty ass doing
this [__] podcast on a
Thursday um much better
mood much better mood than on Monday oh
my God Billy [__] Blues Traveler
there [__] head in the oven Jesus
Christ you know face in the blender
something that's a big place to commit
suicide right in the kitchen if you had
to do it like like top five appliances
to kill yourself
with we all know stove is number one
right they're like the Yankees most
[__] championships the most [__]
deaths has got to be the
stove right I would say
uh what's another way to do it we could
take the shelving out of your
refrigerator close the
door suffocate and cold I don't think
that's a good way to do it blender's too
messy falling a mop you know right on
the handle I don't know it's [__]
dark man
um yeah Kitchen in the bathroom that's
what people do it and it's funny that
that's like that's the number one thing
that sells a house kitchens and
bathrooms and then ironically enough
like that's the number one and number
two place where you might end up killing
yourself in your dream
house speaking of houses congratulations
on that corporation that snatched up
homes in Las Vegas bought up 3500 homes
just like that just like that just
[__] bought them right up you know
just when you thought the banks were
going to take away the American dream of
owning a [__] house are the banks
just tapping out now and whatever the
name of this [__] Corporation is you
know that's something you won't see
either [__] uh sleepy Joe or crooked
Donald those two dumb [__] which
evidently are going to be our
uh our um choices this is what [__] I
don't I just don't get Do You Remember
When Donald Trump got elected can you
remember that far
back and all the Liberals peed
themselves and then all the [__]
racist morons were like it's going to be
great again man right and nothing really
happened I remember when he got elected
there was people going like this was
[__] white people going we're taking
our country back because the last
president was black now what I don't
understand was like but the that the
country elected a black guy two times in
a row so where were all those angry
white people that didn't want a black
president the same way I don't
understand is if Biden beat Trump the
last
time and they're like oh he's coming
this time he's going to win it's like
well where are all those liberals that
[__] voted against him where are they
going to
go you know and then the Trump people
like well he didn't win it they they
[__] stole it and it's like well then
why wouldn't they steal it
again like none of it m it makes as much
sense as the [__] prevent defense to
me all of these these
um these theories on why people get
elected or why they don't get elected or
why they're coming back none of that
[__]
[__] makes sense to
me you know I was joking last night on
that Epstein Island list everybody
talking about this list that's coming
out or it came out it was just like well
what was the [__] point of killing
the guy if there was going to be a l you
kill somebody so the information doesn't
get out like none of it [__] makes
sense now there's a
list oh jeez this is why I don't I don't
watch the news anymore I am a simple
man I am a simple man or maybe maybe
just maybe I'm
smart and I realize that there is no
[__] way you can have any sort of
intelligent
discourse about anything anymore so at
least not over social
media you know what I
mean somebody sending me a clip of that
UFC fighter and that that [__]
liberal reporter going back and
forth and uh everybody you know chews an
upside Ides on that and the whole
[__] it's just like what just
happened to just the
fights like why am I listening to
political things why am I listening to
somebody go who did you vote for it's
like it's none of your [__] business
and then oh that means you're [__]
dead what a woo it's like back in the
day like there was an unbelievably
private question none of your [__]
business Andy didn't walk around saying
who you voted for you didn't bring up
politics you didn't bring up
religion there was a Mohammad Ali would
make up jokes and rhymes about how ugly
the other guy was and that he wasn't
going to win you
know he kept it racial he made it very
very racial Joe Fraser's and Uncle Tom
he did all of that [__] all of that that
that's you kept it at
that um and now it's all [__] changed
you got to walk around like I saw this
[__] jerk off when I was up in the
mountains
there it's said
uh oh God what did it say first of all
he had a trump bumper sticker so he let
you know who he voted for and then it
was like California born and raised and
it was just like this is like so [__]
like teenage girl you know like oh my
God so I was born in California born and
raised these are my favorite bands I
mean all over this guy's [__] Jeep it
was like he was just letting everybody
like he's so [__] interest like I
don't give a [__] where you were born I
don't give a [__] who you voted for all
I give a [__] is that when the light
turns green you
go and don't try to pass me on the right
if you're on my bumper I'm not going to
break check you I'm going to go over to
the right and I'm going to let you go by
me I've reached that level of maturity
in my driving it took 55 years but I
finally do it now if somebody's on my
[__]
ass um I just go you know what they're
in a [__] mood and they going to
cause an accident but not with me and I
just I just I I go into Victory
formation I just take a knee I just go
right over to the right and you know
what you know what it's [__]
liberating rather than getting into that
huge fight I saw that fight this morning
I was taking my wife out to
coffee this guy pulled out in front of
me like a douche I didn't beep at him
like all right there was a move and then
he went to the left lane uh it was a two
little two-lane road and then you know
cut off else and that person just got on
the
horn for like a quarter mile so the guy
starts break checking them right and
what I loved it was like that could have
been me but I decided to not get
involved and now this guy's involved and
it's in a different Lane so now I'm
getting a free show this is fantastic so
I got to give a shout out to the guy
that that uh was break checking him
because he slowed down as the light was
counting down I was going Nia watch
watch he's going to make this guy miss
the light and it's exactly what he did
he waited for it to turn red and then he
punched it left the guy at the light
like Axel
Foley in the first Beverly Hills Cop
remember ah [__] why do I always try to
drink a full can of [__] water laying
on my
back
stupid speaking of that I was out at a
restaurant with my children and I made
the rookie dad mistake
my son had a full drink with no top on
it and I moved it away from the edge and
I made the mistake of not moving it all
the way where he couldn't touch it and I
looked away for like a second and a half
and then I just
heard I looked over it was all over
him oh and then you got to go you got to
go outside you got to go back up to the
room you got to change and all of that
stuff uh fortunately Nia was like don't
worry I'll do
it and I was like are you sure she goes
yeah this food sucks anyways and it did
it did suck
um and mine wasn't good either which was
amazing cuz I ordered avocado to avocado
toast it's kind of amazing when somebody
can [__] up a meal where literally the
name of the meal is also all the
ingredients
mine is some salt and pepper or whatever
they put tomato on it it just it it
wasn't bad it just wasn't good but like
I don't know was just one of those
[__] places you know you get excited
if you're going to go out to breakfast
but then when it's like mediocre or or
even worse
bad you just you just feel wronged is
like how did you don't even understand
how it happened like what
happened I do have to tell you it's it's
how do how do you [__] up
breakfast I mean everything about
breakfast is
delicious bacon eggs
potatoes pancakes waffles French
toast I mean
coffee it's [__] it's the best meal
of the day like what what could you
possibly how could you [__] these up me
all of those things Salt and Pepper or
butter and syrup and it's done seasoned
at the very least the worst it's just
going to be really
good but every once in a while you just
go to a place and somehow
someway they're going to figure out a
[__] way to [__] it
up eggs are runny toast is
cold I don't they're going to
[__] try to get cute and and and and
put some some weird ass Spice in
there so they they can they can they can
seem I don't know what
interesting don't don't be interesting
just be good just be good get the
[__] job done four in the floor just
lay it
down oh I went to the gym today threw
the [__] weights around a little
bit had a good time took my lovely lady
out to breakfast after uh we dropped the
kids off at school my son is like a
[__] ACDC Maniac now
um you know he watched that clip of me
uh jamming with some of the guys from
uh uh uh Skid Row Scotty and snake you
know we played Highway to Hell and my
son's been walking around the house
singing Highway to Hell but like doing
it in like a little kid way like he
doesn't quite sing it right and then
both my kids are uh singing the ACDC
song walk all over you cuz I I got to
play that at Dean Del ra uh Bon Scott
bash and I'm not going to lie to you I
watched that clip like [__] 200 times
I was so happy with my drumming like
that's the best I've looked and sounded
and I also saw a lot of room from
Improvement and [__] so was very uh
anyway but now it's really funny cuz
like you know ACDC in the morning is uh
that's a lot now I can handle it cuz you
know I grew up on that [__] but Nia oh
my God it's [__]
hilarious we be in the car my son's like
Dad I want
ACDC what an
ACDC my wife is not a morning person so
she's just looking over me so I try to
you know you try to go easy you try to
go like Bon Scott ride on like one of
the few ballads they ever did um but we
usually end up
uh like Brian Johnson is too much in the
morning you need to go Bond
Scott uh especially early Brian Johnson
oh my God I mean he's just [__] is
belting me lungs out remember he says
that about getting in the studio I
looked over my shoulder I felt like one
Scott was standing there I know I just
buting me lungs
out [__] love that guy so
um
anyway been doing a lot of that stuff
and also when I was at the gym I was
listening to Judas Priest uh here's a
[__]
um and I know this sounds like really
old guy [__] but all of you young people
this is what you're going to do I if if
you're lucky enough to live a long life
I don't give a [__] how much you pay
attention to new music when you go to
the gym you're going back to your te
years you have to do it to get you to
just get [__] pumped up to go to the
gym so
underrated uh Judas Priest song I would
say is turning
circles that breakdown part was going
aha aha
aha
aha um turnning
circus [__] Judas Priest rules and if
you saw old dad old dads you saw that we
had the great Rob howford made a cameo
in that can talk about that now the
movie's been out long enough and um I
got to direct the scene via
Zoom with him and C Thomas Howell um two
Heroes of mine from when I was a kid and
uh it
was like I got to work face to face with
C Thomas how he was just salt of the
earth [__] great dude and then um Rob
hord I only got to do that via zoom and
uh he could not have
been a cooler guy it was just it was
awesome you know they always say you
don't want to meet your Heroes most of
the times they're [__] cool it's just
when they're not it's so devastating it
kind of [__]
I think wipes out all the cool moments
that you had but
um but I I'm trying to think like I've
only had a couple of times where I just
had a bad interaction with
someone um kareim Abdul Jabar but I kind
of knew that was coming and I knew not
to approach him but my wife just wanted
a picture so bad I'm like this guy does
not like to take pictures with
people H oh my God whenever I see his
face I just uh I just think like oh why
did I go up to
him
anyway however that does not taint how I
look at him as a basketball player at
all at all um I still think he's in the
argument him or magic is the greatest
Lakers of all
time um I stand by that um anyway that's
my [__] two
cents and I'm sticking with it I did
some standup last night
I was playing with that Epstein Island
idea and uh a couple of other things it
was just a really fun show down at The
Comedy
Store uh Fahim anoir show where he just
does like all [__] new jokes and
stuff up in the belly room it was kind
of the perfect thing cuz I just wanted
to [__] around and guys I'm not Fu I'm
not kidding you I haven't done another
special I already have like hour 20 90
minutes and I've written like another
new 20 minutes and when I take my
special this year I don't give a [__]
like 20 minutes of my ACT is going out
the window and or whatever I'm it's just
going to
be all the good ones I'm a big believer
in that cuz I had a buddy of M go well
now you're writing like a new 20 minutes
so like what are you going to do with
that other stuff I was like just [__]
Let It
Go it'll it'll pop up at some point on
something I don't know what but like I
am a big believer in you do your best
[__] I Al I always felt that way when um
you know if you were doing
like a five minute thing on Conan or
Letterman or uh Comedy Central or even
like um when I got to host SNL it's like
you go out with your best [__] don't
save it for your
special [__] that you you'll write other
[__] just because you'll have to because
you burned it and then um what I like is
if you only did it on like an SNL or
Comedy Central it becomes like this
bside bit for people to find years later
when they oh they thought they watched
all your specials like um that Steve
Jobs bit I did on um I forget what
channel that was on and I like that one
because every once in a while like
someone will just F randomly find it and
be like that wasn't on any of your
specials man that was a great [__]
bit blah blah blah blah blah I always
get like
psyched that uh it ends up in I always
feel like in the long run it becomes a
good thing cuz you just want like
especially not because there's just so
many [__] podcasts everything
everything you do has to be in that
moment the the highest quality you can
you can put out there because the
competition is uh is uh it's just I
don't know there's just a zillion
[__] people so I I I don't think that
you can kind of like I remember back in
the 80s like you catch Comics doing TV
spots overlapping bits I actually repeat
I you know what's funny cuz I never
watch my [__] specials I did a joke
to specials in a row
though and I didn't even know I did I
couldn't remember I added it onto
something else and some fan wrote oh my
God he said you did the same joke two
specials in a row I like cringed and I
just laughed I was just like all right
well you
[Music]
know the world's an imperfect
place um so you know as much as I'm
doing that like I I I definitely
uh I definitely [__] up up here or there
but uh well more than here or there so
anyways I'm sitting here in my drum room
um just staring at my drums as I'm
talking to you guys and I got to be
honest with you like this is I used to
do this when I was a kid when I thought
I was going to make it in a band or
something I used to go downstairs I was
so into playing and it was like cuz I
hadn't done standup yet so this was sort
of my only like Outlet of like it's what
I liked about it I just felt it comine
the art world and the sports world is
what always appealed to me about
drumming and then just the whole primal
thing about
drums um especially the
toms um how they made you feel and all
of that uh and I used to I used to go
down my parents unfinished basement
right
um I used to sit on like the like they
just like raw wood stairs right one of
those types of houses and I would eat
dinner and I would just be sitting there
staring at
[Music]
them like how you would look at like a
classic car or some [__] um but anyway
you know what's funny like I that's how
I used to like
judge a whether a family was rich slash
had their [__] together cuz I knew my
family I knew we were
crazy um not necessarily bad but we were
[__] nuts and I used to judge it by
whether or not you had a finished
basement like if I went over your house
and you had like a normal amount of [__]
that like you could walk through a
living room like we just had a bunch of
[__] we had you know it was
like uh I would remember how this you
ever watch Sanford and Son all that [__]
like we didn't have it outside it was
and it was like my parents were like
into Antiques and stuff so like there
was this this hodge podge
of all different errors like it looked
like a furniture store they just were
into antiquin they just did that [__]
and they would [__] buy this stuff
and somehow find like room for it like
in our kitchen we had a regular stove
and then we had one of those
oldfashioned little rascal stoves that
was like up on like
legs um and then that just became
something you know he never used it it
just became something to stick books and
all of this [__] on top like Hoarders
they were like sort of high-end or I
would say nostalgic hoarders I think is
the way to put it it wasn't like
high-end but it was like uh it was um
yeah it was an
interesting expression of consumerism um
so anyway when I would that's why I
[__] to this day I can't stand
clutter because it was just it it just
over the years it just kept going and
going and going and it just became like
like there's no place place to even just
lay on the floor and stretch before I I
you know go to the gym or something cuz
there's just so much [__] [__] and
um so anyway I would go over other
people's houses and I would be
fascinated with with how they didn't
have nearly as much
[__]
um and uh and then you would go
downstairs and they would have like a
finished basement and I used to always
think like why don't we do that you know
that cuz that's a big thing you know
when you were a kid you'd go out other
people's houses and they always looked
like they had their [__] together but my
parents also didn't drink and uh a lot
of my friends parents you'd go over
their houses and they were like [__]
you know they would still be getting
blasted and I thought that that was a
cool thing when I was young and then as
I got older I'm like well that's
probably
not the
best
example d show like I was talking to one
of my high school buddies right like I
still you know talked to so many people
that I went to high school with like uh
I I had a really
really cool graduating class um and I
was talking to one of them and he was
saying
like how by the time he was in the fifth
grade he knew how to make a Manhattan he
could make a dude I can make a matini I
mean what do you want and it was just
like it was like one of the things like
when you had a
kid you know aside from like wanting to
teach him how to throw a ball it was
also like you had a kid so you had a
bartender or a bartender and they used
to have like I remember I would go
over this kid's house and his parents
would be watching the game and we would
come in from playing like you know
baseball or football outside back when
kids played outside and [__] riding
bikes and they would come in and they'
be like so and so go make me a [__]
blah blah he wouldn't say [__] but go
make make me this or whatever and he
would go behind the bar and I would just
be fascinated with that world like holy
[__] like his parents over here [__]
drinking this is this is
cool and
uh I don't know it is still kind of cool
but it was a little too cool if you know
what I mean you know there's there's
there there's something about it like
uh you know it's good you're socializing
your kids young but
also I don't know it didn't feel bad
because alcohol was legal like if they
were saying hey can you roll me a
joint that would have seemed like holy
[__] am I on like you know some Narco
show cuz obviously it wasn't legal back
then but uh anyway I'm sitting here
babbling let's do uh let's do
um let's do some reads here for the week
and uh oh yeah did I mention how I was
listening to that that Jackson 5
song uh dancing machine and James Gadson
plays the drums on it and just what a
absolutely it's a
masterpiece um what he plays on that and
uh I've listened to that song a hundred
times this week and each time I hear
something just a little that I I that I
missed and
um I don't know I know there's been
documentaries about it but that that
[__] time when they were those Studio
musicians just going around
town um I still don't think that they I
know that they've done stuff about The
Wrecking
Crew
um I always forget the names it was the
guys in m toown and then there was the
guys out here Hal Blaine and all of
those guys and that woman that played
the bass I should know her name she
[__] played on all of these
albums um you know my uh couple drummers
that I've gotten to know have told me
about it the guy one of my my flight
instructors also an incredible piano
player he was involved in that scene
Randy Waldman and he was talking about
just going around town and how like
there was so much
work that he had like an open call to
like some of these Studios that did like
commercial Jingles like if you can just
going going from one session to another
if you can swing by he could just go in
and knock out like a [__] you know
some sort of piano thing for a Crest
commercial and he would make money doing
that too was really just just a really
an amazing
time um and now that I think they just
do it all on computers or whatever but
whatever times change not going to get
depressed I'm going to stay up staying
up all right look who it is everybody
look who it is oh it's old
zip
recruiter um according to Forbes January
is the hottest month for hiring doesn't
get any sexier than January um and
business owners and hiring managers are
on the hunt for top talent which is no
easy task if you're currently hiring you
can probably relate it's challenging to
find qualified candidates that's why you
need
zip zip recruit is powerful matching
technology finds the right people for
your roles fast and right now you can
try it for free at ziprecruiter.com bur
here is how
zip uh why it's so effective at finding
top talent uh immediately after you post
your job zip recruit of smart technology
start showing you candidates whose
skills and experience match it to
encourage top candidates to respond to
your job uh to your job post even sooner
zip let you send them a personal invite
to apply this month find the talent you
need to fill all of your roles with
zip uh see for yourself why four to five
employees who post uh on zip recruiter
get a qualified candidate within the
first day just go to this exclusive web
address right now to try
[Music]
zip uh for free at ziprecruiter.com bur
again that's ziprecruiter.com B RR
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
that last one was a baby bird calling
for its mother as a different bird of
prey lands near the nest and it has a
feeling that his feathers and its days
are numbered um anyway all right that's
the podcast how about those Buffalo
those [__] [__] I decided at the
beginning of the year I was like I don't
think the Pat's going to be that good
all right I know I'm going to get my hat
broken I didn't see Bill bich leaving at
the end uh I am so relieved that that is
over I'm glad that that happened
swiftly and dare I say eloquently it all
left on good terms he had a nice press
conference and then they immediately had
someone fill the role I thought I
thought the whole thing was done is they
they ripped the bandaid off which I
thought was great for everyone involved
including the fans so um I decided that
I was going to cheer on the Buffalo
Bills you know let's cheer these guys on
you know they haven't W let's finally
you know give get Buffalo a goddamn
Championship already
right and then I experienced what it was
like to be a Buffalo Bills fan it's just
like I don't need this [__] so I kind of
walked away from in the middle of the
season and uh yeah I like I don't need
to take this on
you know I'm I'm just like you know
because as I said like there's something
you know when your team
sucks like the regular season sucks but
I will tell you this the playoffs
playoffs are
fantastic because I can just enjoy these
games I don't have to sit here and die a
thousand deaths rooting for my team my
team is [__] long gone out of it
since like you know mathematically
probably since the second week of
[__] October it was over so I can
just sit here enjoy this so uh I'm you
know I'm an underdog guy so bills have
never won it even though they sort of
underperformed who gives a [__] it's the
second season now and they're 1 and0 so
I'm rooting for them I like the
Texans uh who else I can't root for the
49ers because they're the favorites I
feel um and Jesus Christ the [__]
Eagles at least they put their fans out
of their [__]
misery um
yeah that was that was a uh a rough one
I'm glad that they're going to stick
with uh uh Nick Serano that that made no
[__] sense like if they were going to
get rid of him that was all these idiots
like there was obviously I mean first of
all they would you Super Bowl last year
okay yeah great and then he lost his
offensive and defensive
coordinator another reason why belich
was so [__] great you win the Super
Bowl everybody gets jobs Charlie Weiss
going to [__] uh where'd he go went
to Notre Dame [__] Matt Patricia
where you went to the Lions what
everybody gets head coaching jobs and in
in the college and the pros and all of
that um it's really hard to keep it
going that long so um I was surprised
the
Cowboys are are sticking with uh what's
his
face Mike uh Michael McDonald we're
going to win the Super bowl next year um
I don't remember anybody's name all
right sorry sorry for the bad
impression Tony Romo couldn't get it
done and neither could I press God maybe
we should trade for
somebody Jerry has Botox in his face all
right this is getting stupid okay that's
it everybody that's the podcast I'm in
my [__] garage here I got to go back
to uh the writer's room the other side
of my garage into the office here all
right that's it go [__] yourself have a
great weekend you [__] and I'll talk to
you on
[Music]
Monday hey what's going on it's Bill bur
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday January 18th
2016 how's it going how are
you uh I am recording this Sunday
afternoon and uh in
Vancouver uh Canada doing two shows here
tonight it's half time actually third
quarter just started of the uh Broncos
Steelers I missed uh Seattle and uh
Carolina I know that must have been a
great [__] game it kills me you know
you never know when you book the [__]
gigs that a game like that is going to
be on but uh I imagine that that was uh
as good as the score looked and of
course I'm up here in Canada and uh I
don't know they don't have they just
went to Boomer and all those guys at
halftime and all they did was Interview
Cam Newton they asked him one question
you know he he didn't answer you know he
just talked didn't give an answer about
anything they like what do you think he
did the uh the second half to uh you
know uh blah blah blah blah and he just
goes well you know our offense and our
defense and of course the Special Teams
you know everybody's got a job to do and
uh they get out there and they try to
get done and fortunately today we were
able to get out there and execute some
of the things we've been working with
all this week and uh you know next week
we got another person that we're going
to be playing I should set a team not a
person we got a team we're going to play
and uh we just hope that uh you know
we're just going to try to keep it going
because uh you know we're trying to win
Championship
here and by then you're just like I did
what the [__] did I even ask
you
um I wonder if you know cuz athletes
anything they [__] say they're going
to take it out of context so they just
they get trained to just answer and not
say anything just like a politician I
wonder if you can [__] turn that off
you know if you stay in the league long
enough if you drive your wife nuts you
know honey do you know where my shoes
are well you know you own you own a lot
of stuff and uh sometimes that stuff
gets misplaced but all you can do is
just try to fire in all cylinders and
try to find the things that you can have
and uh if you can find them you can find
them and if you can't uh then you got to
move on to the next thing but uh you
know as always I'm always looking
towards next week and another thing
that's going to be lost and uh if it's
lost we're definitely going to do
everything we can to find it uh the
offense defense and the Special
Teams you're not helping
me
um anyways uh yeah so I'm up here in
Vancouver God damn it it's [__]
beautiful up here
[__] gorgeous man especially when you
live in uh you know where the hell I
live which was not designed to have
really anybody living there other than I
guess maybe some indigenous people
sending smoke signals you know probably
sending smoke signals that you know can
you find any food cuz we can't I'm sick
of eating
snake and do you want to get the [__]
out of here however the [__] you do that
with smoke signals it must have been
pretty goddamn simple right the smoke
signals if they even did it or is that
just another Hollywood would think that
they threw a blun I mean how do you even
[__] do that I guess you obviously
you got to put the fire out
right I would I how the [__] would you
do that you
know all right one big puff of [__]
you got to know what kind of wood to
burn what a pain in the
ass Jesus Christ you know mean to get
lost at remember getting lost at the
mall before a [__] cell phone that
was unbelievable forget about back then
if you get lost you were
[__] hey anybody see uh what the [__]
was that guy's
name oh [__] red face where did he go
don I mean how long do you
look you can't really yell you're going
to attract wild
animals just walking around the woods
hey Eddie Eddie the [__] are you this
isn't funny
man um anyways but you come up here
after leaving the dessert um whenever I
see say the desert I always think of uh
that awesome that great Greg Geraldo
rust the soul joke where he used just
did that whole thing about uh how
eloquent the words the words the notes
were that uh soldiers wrote during the
Civil
War you know versus some of the letters
from people coming back from RE
[Music]
Iraq H what am I I can't remember how
the [__] went it's really hard to be
out here with your ball sticking to your
leg out here in the in the
dessert you know I remember the
difference between desert and dessert
two s's for dessert more calories right
there you go that's how I do it and
don't even ask me to spell restaurant
because I won't even [__] remember so
anyways I'm up here in Vancouver so we
go to [__]
land um and just oh my God all the Lush
Greenery all the Lakes all the water
everything we don't have down in La
beautiful houses I guess it's expensive
as [__] up here and they were saying how
um a lot of Asian people um you know not
indigenous foreigners you know they got
to get rid of their [__] money they
got to wash their money or I don't know
what the [__] it is their government's
going to take it all so they uh use this
place up here like a Swiss bank and they
buy like super expensive places for
cash um which drives the housing market
up it's [__] nuts man anytime you go
to another country you just hear the
[__] that they're [__] dealing with I
just you know you always think like you
come up here Canada is going to have no
[__] problems you know you watch one
Michael Moore documentary that just
gives you a complete like
misinterpretation of what the [__] is
going on up here um so they I guess they
had to make some sort of
law
um that you couldn't do something like
that I can't I can't what the [__]
person told him went all the way all the
way to the [__] Supreme Court it was
like a group of people from Asia that
was so rich that they actually sued an
entire country for not letting them
either come into the country or
or uh buy a bunch of [__] over here that
drove the housing market stuff up or
something like that or buy their
citizenship I can't even [__]
remember but that's the charm of this
podcast you know I get a little
information I barely remember half of it
and I just [__] run with it that's
all um so anyways
um so it went all the way to the Supreme
Court and then they were just finally
like uh yeah you kind of have to be from
this country for us to give a [__] about
you you know to like win a lawsuit so uh
see you later and that's and it ended I
guess the lawyer for them knew the whole
way going all the way up that it wasn't
going to happen you know they weren't
going to win it he just took their money
he probably had to sit there and work on
his uh I'm disappointed we lost two face
you know as he took all their [__]
money but anyways so let's talk about
NFL
football um the [__] uh
Patriots they won godamn it thank Christ
they won thank Christ they won and
Seattle lost thank
Christ you know we're going to keep
advancing I just didn't want Seattle to
get the Revenge I can't remember if I if
I've already said this I just didn't
want to see Seattle get the revenge on a
banged up Patriot team if we come in
healthy and they kick our ass good on
them but uh you know congratulations to
the Carolina Panthers uh they got to be
the favorites at this point come on
they're 16 and [__] one right got
that young defense they're not scared of
[__] they just beat Seattle right who
knows but um I don't know [__] about
football i' I've just been so [__]
busy so I'm I'm still going to talk
about it you guys can keep trashing me
that I don't know [__] I don't give a
[__] um and by the way this is why I
never record on a day that I flew
because my brain is even more all over
the place than it usually is especially
when I got a [__] TV going on in the
background but uh you know I I got I got
a busy [__] day I fly back tomorrow I
got a busy [__] day so I apologize if
this is all over the place even more
than usual is a first down for the
Steelers and more the're four 40 the 30
the're [__]
25 I hope somebody else up here gives a
[__] about NFL football I know there CFL
ends in like is it the end of November
they have the gray cup which is their
Super Bowl or is it uh December I don't
know do people even give a [__] you ever
see the [__] stadiums for their
football teams up here it's like you sit
in the stands you can see your car you
know one of those deals where there's
like a [__] you watch him kick a
field goal and you're looking at traffic
driving by on the
street like those old school football
stadiums uh from like the 60s and 7s you
know where they they would have like the
horseshoe shaped
Stadium which was I think what happened
with with this with football stadiums
was when there wasn't that many people
in the OR and also the leagues were
small they just had people sitting on
both sides right you had the home side
and the visitor side and that was it and
then there there's more and more people
population got bigger the leagues got
bigger then they built Endzone seats
that connected both sides I think they
just did it on one side first then you
had the Horseshoe right like the [__]
uh Broncos played in the Buckey the
Buckey still call it their hor they
still call it a horseshoe even though
they [__] closed it in and then
eventually there was people did so much
[__] that they had to close you know
and there's so much
ESPN that got everybody [__]
interested in it that isn't even
interested in it then all of a sudden
Beyonce is singing at [__] halftime
you know and there's a bunch of people
in the crowd that are excited by it you
know um a [__] old ass Rod Stewart
who the [__] they dragging out they
always either go with somebody young or
they just [__] drag somebody who out
who's on their last [__] legs like
their last big payday you know they just
[__] wheel them out
there who are they going to do this
year U Night Ranger it's either going to
be like Night Ranger or Drake that's
what I'm guessing oh wait I think it is
Beyonce you know I know cuz Nia wanted
to go to the Super Bowl because Beyonce
was there I'm like why don't you go see
her in
concert you're going to make us go to
the [__] Super Bowl and then we going
to watch your lip sync one [__] song
how the [__] did Shawn Penn interview
that drug
lord how do you do something like that
and the government isn't like hey you
know we're trying to find that guy you
know when you're sitting there ping
around with
him probably bought him like Fast Times
at Ridgemont High DVDs right for his
underground
[Music]
layer dude I Love Shawn Penn as an actor
but how out of your [__] tree are
you that you're going to go and
interview that [__]
guy you know I I just
that's I'm trying to think how many
[__] standup
specials I would have to put out before
I could go I would go [__] interview
somebody and like I the well I guess
Isis is actually fighting but we're
[__] with them too you
know I would just think I'm going to
walk in there with my microphone they're
all going to laugh at me and then
they're going to saw my [__] head off
or even worse tie me to a chair
[__] torture me to death that's
insane hey good on
him also I don't is it El Chapo that's
his name he sounds like such a gentleman
huh Elche he's a good chap El
Chapo
um I don't [__] get it
man what are you
doing why why did he go down there and
interview that
guy and like how how
how well does Shawn Penn's movies
do that drug dealer on the Run he's on
the run from our government right isn't
this the guy who escaped I don't [__]
know you know what's going on is my
[__] internet won't let me sign on so
I can't [__] see anything I can't see
the [__]
highlights nothing you know all I'm up
here is I [__] got one goddamn
Channel and a bunch of Tim Horton
[__] commercials which is their
Dunkin Donuts see if I can sign on here
isn't El Chapo the guy that
like that we would that keeps escaping
from jail is that the guy El Chapo come
on man come on ah this connection is
untrusted yeah Jesus
Christ it's probably some psycho from
Alberta trying to hack in here that
seems like they're Texas to me when
you're up here it's all [__] oil men
and ranchers and [__] um and then you
got
Edmonton Edmonton seems like it's nice
you know what I mean like that that's
their like business Hub you know I'm
totally judging these just by doing like
driving through and and doing a little
bit of standup out here like when I did
stand up in Calgary great people but
[__] animals Jesus [__] Christ
they were animals I don't know it's
because the place that we performed at
there was like no carpeting or nothing
they were [__] I think it was also
cuz it was bring your own beer [__]
animals I would never [__] with anybody
from
Calgary I saw the way they behaved when
they were in a good mood ex excited for
a show don't have a [__] with anybody
from
Calgary I went to Edmonton it was
civilized Calgary Jesus
Christ they had everything but a hooker
swinging from a swing you know back in
the old days with the saloons where they
had the hores you know way overdressed
once again it might just be a [__]
movie thing so much so much of my
history is is based on that by the way I
can't get on the [__] internet but
for some reason
I can [__]
uh I can do it over the uh I can do it
on my phone let me look up El Chapo here
like I said he sounds like such a chap I
just think like that English
thing
Chapo he a Mexican
chap how Mexico secretly launched a
Crackdown after Penn met El Chapo how El
Chapo was finally captured again that
was one day ago will El Chapo rat out
rival C tells corrupt officials it's got
to be a lot of stress being this El
Chapo guy
huh waen
Guzman you know I got to say he looks
like a Mexican Robert Blake like during
the Beretta years now when he says uh
yeah that's me who's also on the phone
and then starts laughing how else this
is when you know you lived a [__]
crazy life this is just the front page
of this guy's if you search this guy's
name how El Chapo was finally captured
again will El Chapo read those uh El
Chapo Guzman Sean pen talks about him El
Chapo had erectile dysfunction surgery
while on the Run that's nice now he took
a pit stop you know guy takes care of
himself how nervous was that doctor
working on that maniac's
dick uh El Chapo speaks Rolling Stone
Shawn Penn has terrible regret about
meeting El Chapo well what did he think
he was going to
meet he's going to get some [__]
sherries berries the hunt for El Chapo
Wen El Chapo Guzman the truth about the
jailbreak there's nothing here about uh
an older wiser El Chapo puts out a
little singer
songwriter Jesus [__] Christ dude you
know realiz how [__] finished we are
just as as a as as a just as a
race not as a race as Humanity that's
I'm trying to say just as people we're
[__]
done you know Rolling Stone Rolling
Stone this month has Shawn Penn talking
to El
Chapo and Leonardo DiCaprio's on the C
cover and they're billing him he has a
plan to save the
planet what are we doing what the [__]
is their government not doing that
A-list [__] uh
actress have to talk to drug lords and
try to save the planet I mean there's
got to be how many leaks are in the
[__] Dam at this point I don't know
about you guys that does not make me
feel comfortable you know what I mean
Boomer is cin to
uh figure out how to uh [__] colonize
Mars that's the next thing that they're
going to have in the rolling rolling
stone you know why why the [__] do I
want to hear
that can I hear a
scientist you
know how about have a Navy SEAL
interview El
Chapo I don't know Bill how about you
shut the the [__] up all right I will I
don't know I get unsettled I get
unsettled and my then I have problems
with
digestion um I can't even remember what
the [__] I was going to look
up what was I initially looking up
before I got to El
Chapo Jesus Christ some of the stories
on that
guy you know it's right up there with
that [__] Rod Stewart rumor from way
back in the day remember that
one I think it was I can't remember if
Rob to whatever they yeah they found
like a gallon of jizz in his stomach his
stomach had to be pumped you know a
[Laughter]
gallon he went to Trader Joe's and
bought some [__] allnatural organic
[__] I'm
sorry um he got a gallon of it you know
no he went to uh where's those what's
that place where you buy everything in
bulk those [__] whales are pushing
around those pallet jacks buying
Cheerios
you got to get a membership to it begins
with a c it's not Cy what's what's the
name of that sh I never go to the
[__] place once I had to go in there
and get a
membership they wanted on this [__]
information
um oh Christ what the [__] is it called
not coach
Che I'm never going to remember it you
know what I'm saying that just kills the
jokes bill when you can't remember the
[__] references it just it absolutely
kills it
Costco hey went to Costco he bought one
of those big [__] uh gallons of
[__] jizz and on a dare he chugged it
anyway so this here something on El
Chapo El Chapo they said
uh I can't remember like just [__]
killed this person's whole family took
their kids and some I this why I don't
believe it though took his kids and then
flew him to
uh to Colombia and then threw him off a
bridge it's like really that there's not
any bridges in uh Mexico you never know
what to believe but I got to tell you
when you go south
of the US you do not want to piss
anybody off as far as I can tell that's
some Next Level [__] and I can say that
because I just read papers from the
United
States they
uh that's just that's just next level
like you know you're mad at somebody and
then you know how you get your revenge
is just some next I I read that uh
killing Pablo one time I had to put the
book down like three times some of the
[__] they just said that the guy did now
I don't know the [__] guy did this
[__] but I remember one time hearing
that the guy had a
party right and everybody's out there by
the pool standing around you know and uh
what's his face
there Pablo Escobar standing there you
know everybody's ignoring the weight
that he's putting on as he sits there in
his [__] Hager action slacks you know
he seemed to like those he's
stretched and uh you know still tucked
him in right at the waist you know what
I mean tucked him right in the waist
didn't push the pants down didn't do the
[__] shirt un tucked he tucked it
right in and uh they said that he
allegedly found one of his uh one of the
people you one of his not his but one of
the maids I don't know what allegedly
was stealing so they tied this guy's
legs together and his arms behind the
his back and they threw him in the house
pool and just watched him drown as
everyone was standing there at the party
you
know I'd say there must have been a lot
of ice shaking and drinks after that one
like
so is this a Victorian
house Pablo Mr Escobar I don't want to
go in the pool um yeah people getting
their faces ripped off is it Torture to
death they're like peeling their [__]
faces back this is not funny this is not
what this podcast is about um why is
this [__] Steeler Denver game so
[__]
boring is it because I have the sound
down I just don't give a
[__] the AFC is just the walk
wounded rburg was a [__] man look at
the guy just getting bumped by lme and
he stays in there that guy he has like
[__] he stays in the pocket like
Steve Grogan used to used to stay in the
pocket did anybody remember that any old
Pats fans out there you'd [__] sit
there and this is back when you could
literally you could Hammer a [__]
quarterback drive your helmet right
under his chin and then lift him off the
ground and pile drive them into the
[__]
AstroTurf which is like getting tackled
in a parking lot that's been uh painted
green and Steve Gro remember he would go
back for a pass this is back when he had
that [__] neck brace and he had such
a long neck he could still see like six
inches of neck right even with the neck
brace and there'd be some defensive
lineman just running full speed right at
him and he he would just hang on to it
hang on to it hang on to it and then he
would throw the ball and the camera
would follow the football and right as
he let it go you'd see just the
beginning of that [__] lineman
Drilling him and he'd go flying right
out the right side of your screen or
left side depending on which way he was
going down the field to Stanley
Morgan you know Russ Francis one of
those [__] guys right Harold
Jackson who else did we have back then I
can't even [__]
remember Hasselbeck we had Hasselbeck
whose son was the one who said uh we
want the ball and we're going to
score Don Hassel back I think was his
dad all right anyways where where the
[__] am
I um yeah rothberg is like that that guy
stands in the pocket and takes a [__]
hit and speaking which too uh I know
there's a lot of Kansas City fans are
probably pissed off at the calls Tom
Brady got and the lack of calls that
Alex Smith got and uh I'm a Patriots fan
uh you're absolutely right but that is
not Tom Brady's
fault
okay and I'm hoping most of you guys in
Kansas City can hear what I'm saying
because you're not as upset because you
got to see your baseball team win the
World Series all right so you got that
going for you half of your professional
teams won championships this year that's
pretty [__] good right
um Tom Brady earned those calls okay
this is the if you want Alex Smith to
get those calls in the future in the
future he has to make the NFL owners a
lot more money than he is and that's
just a simple fact and uh people call it
the Tom Brady rules it isn't it's the
Superstar rules you know Jordan gets
away with the push right when was the
last time Kobe Bryant what does Kobe
Bryant have to do to get you know well
he's not healthy anymore but back in the
day you could be standing in the lane
before the [__] game
starts and if he runs into you that
they're going to call it on you he'd
literally have to take he'd have to
[__] tie an axe to the front of his
knee and [__] jump into you and cut
your head off before you know if there
was a way to call offsetting they would
have it's just it's just how it works
but
um I have to say as much as he earned
the calls that one where he was getting
sacked and he switched it to his left
hand and threw it and they still gave
him the call was [__] ridiculous I
even as a Patriots fan I was at home
going oh what the [__] give me a break
but you know I'll take it of course I'll
take it the same way you would have um
but uh I know Kansas City's a great team
and they have you know Smith I think is
going to be a really [__] great
quarterback um but you got to have it
all man you got to have the coach and
the ownership and all that [__] and
lucky enough that we have that in uh in
New England so there you go that's me
trying to not be a
[__] all right and
uh oh God I can't wait to go home and
watch that [__] Carolina Panther game
man I think you're going to see like all
these people that they were saying are
the air apparent to [__] uh Tom Brady
and pton Manning
I think it's uh I think it's what's his
face there on the
Panthers I can't remember his [__]
name what is wrong with me he went to
Auburn right he does the Superman thing
Cam Newton there we
go
um anyways oh I that'll let you guys
know this I'm supposed to read this [__]
here but of course I got to typing my
[__] password which takes
forever come on for [__]
sakes I got to have a [__] 20l
password and numbers cuz God knows
everybody wants to break into my
computer and read my dick jokes here um
oh Andrew asked you guys he said please
ask the listeners to put relevant
subject lines in their emails if they
want them read putting hey doesn't help
with a thousand thousands a week trying
not to miss any of the good ones thanks
um I probably could have niced that up a
little bit he sort of text me that
really quickly um yeah so if if you guys
have a subject whatever uh you know
anything you know
[__] Tom Brady Tom Brady rules or
something like that you know if you just
do that instead of writing like hey dot
dot dot and then in the email be like
what the [__] was with those calls you
know what I mean oh Bill we get it also
if you'd like to follow the the Monday
Morning podcast on
Twitter um it's themmm
podcast um all right and with that it's
time for uh my attempts at reading out
loud and mercifully that's the end of me
reading out loud for this week um here's
a stat I had to look up because D myera
sent me a uh a text not trying to drop
names here by the way I'm on his podcast
this past week U Dar myera sent me a
text this morning he goes how many
quarterbacks have you ever seen in the
NFL have a Hail Mary pass throw a
successful ha Hail Mary pass once in
their career forget about about twice in
the same season and uh I had to go look
it up I was like I got to I got to find
this out man I got to find out
uh you know if anybody's ever done it
because I was like there's no way
anybody's done it in my lifetime of
watching the last 30s something years of
watching football holy [__] I've been
watching football for 38 years oh my God
I'm
old I started watching it religiously in
about
1978 but um yeah about that
7879 Jesus [__] Christ um put it this
way the first Super Bowl I watched was
Super Bowl
12 and they're at 50 so there you go wow
this is going to be my
uh what would that be my 50 not 51st you
[__] idiot my 39th Super Bowl 50us 12
plus I watch 12
right yeah so so that there there you go
yeah there's a lot of people right now
actually think I'm wrong but it's true
it's my 39th I'm going to be watching
anyways let's plow ahead here um so I
looked it up successful Hail
Marys okay um there's only one guy that
I saw since they started keeping the
stat in 1975 at least on Wikipedia I
didn't go to the football reference.com
which I
love
um the one guy who's ever done done it
twice since I kept the stats in 1975
Steve
Bartowski Steve Bartowski and there's no
way to picture Steve Bowski and not have
the song This song go through your head
believe it or not walking on a I never
thought I could be so
free throwing the ball to Billy White sh
Johnson and to another guy yeah he
looked like the Greatest American Hero
he did it 1978 against the Saints and
then he did it again in 1983 against the
49ers in the uh NFC West which back then
was only four teams it was the Los
Angeles
Rams the New Orleans Saints the Atlanta
Falcons and the San Francisco
49ers the quarterbacks are Steve
Bartowski uh 78 Steve barowski Archie
Manning and I think they had a
quarterback controversy
Pat Hayden Vince farag back and
forth uh before Vince farag tried to
take the money and went to the [__]
CFL oh Jesus never saw him again and uh
it would be Steve deberg or Jim plunket
in 78 I did this with [__] Joe
bartnik one time we tried to name all
the starting quarterbacks in the NFL in
1978 we went around the league I saw I
think it was AFC was Bert Jones Bob
greasy Steve Grogan Richard
Todd and Joe Ferguson for the
bills then it was Terry
Bradshaw Dan
pastorini who the [__] was quarterback
for the Browns it was either Mike
fips or uh Brian
cyp and then the Bengals was Kenny
Anderson Kenny the
candle Collins worth said they call him
Kenny the candle cuz one blow and he was
out you ever see that one on NFL films
and they cut to Kenny Anderson he's like
oh [__]
Collinsworth
um and let's see was Craig Morton I'll
just do the AFC because I know this is
[__] driving everybody n but this is
my I have to do it now cuz now it's in
my head Craig Morton was with the orange
crush Broncos Ken
Stabler Kenny snake stabler for the uh
the r Raiders Dan
Fouts the Great Dan Fouts air Corel with
the
Chargers Jim Zorn with Seattle and then
ah [__] there's always one that gets me
who the [__] was with the
Chiefs it was before blackl was after
Len Dawson who the [__] was the
quarterback there's a good one for you
there's some poor bastard in Kansas City
right now screaming
it who the [__] was it I even know I
think like the the Buccaneers Had Gary
Huff Lyn Dicky was out in Green
Bay Jim Hart was in how the [__] do I
remember those I don't remember Kansas
City the Kansas City I gotta look this
up Kansas City chief
quarterback hey it's going to get better
guys I played drums this week out and I
played with uh Colin Haye from Men at
Work all right I'm going to tell that
story in a second here just [__] deal
with this here Kansas City Chiefs
QB
1978 why do I care why do I [__] care
list of Kansas City chief
quarterbacks this is [__] made for me
I'm who's the last person who [__]
went to this starting quarterback season
to
season Jesus they've had some guys here
huh Joe Montana Warren Moon Rich
Ganon all right here we go here we go
backing it up backing it up
1970 I'd never get this Mike Livingston
and Tony Adams this is the one that
always [__] gets
me Lenny Dawson left in
1975 and then Mike Livingston took
over you know there was a guy who played
for the Bengals that Bill Walsh was
talking about he only played for one
season he got [__] injured and Bill
Walsh to this day still said he's the
Great greatest quarterback that he ever
coached but he's probably still trying
to motivate or he was anyways he passed
away probably still trying to motivate
[__] Montana are young even after
they
retired get him to rake the leaves
better that day or some [__] um I can't
remember the guy's [__] name but
that's one to look up
uh anyways so yeah this this week I did
uh Greg Baron show at Largo and uh one
of those things too it's not quite like
the goddamn comic Jam this is one where
they actually have people uh for the
most part it's musicians coming out and
telling funny stories and this is
something that Greg did a number of
years ago and uh he's brought the show
back and um so
anyways let me let me get the lineup
here so I don't [__] this up I did take
a picture of it I'm so [__]
disorganized I apologize um all right so
it was Colin Hay Tom MLL myself and
Chris Fairbanks another comedian so it
was two Comedians and then uh two
musicians and I got to
uh I got to play uh with the band told
some
stories and I got to play with the band
and then afterwards I got to play with
colen hay and we played uh who can it be
now which was uh just beyond a [__]
thrill he he was the nicest [__] guy
so generous to let me
play um and he had this really cool way
that he wanted to bring me out he goes
uh he just went out there he was telling
stories he was [__] hilarious and
then he just randomly goes you know and
I had the weirdest dream last night I
was dreaming I was you know playing a
show and uh I was playing you know who
can it be now and the crowd collaps
because it's such a huge hit and he goes
the weirdest thing you know Bill Burr
was on drums like you know and I just
waited a second then I just walked out
and sat down everybody started laughing
and then he told this great story I'm
not going to repeat the story just
because I it's his story so I'm sure if
he wants to tell it on a podcast he can
but he tells this [__] hilarious
story that ends with the word [__] and
he told me after I say
[__] basically you do the drum Phil
intro and then we'll go into the song
and uh then we played it and it went off
went off pretty good man it actually uh
I don't know it's [__] unreal man I
played like 20 years by myself in a
rehearsal space until it finally dawned
on me that I'm supposed to be out
interacting with other [__] people so
now uh then I've kind of opened
Pandora's Box I just I told you I made
this rule that I'm not going to
ask to sit in but if somebody asked me
to play I'm going to [__] play all
right that includes if I come to your
town and if I'm drinking in a bar if I
go out to a bar and your local band is
playing if you come up to me and ask me
to sit in with your band I'm going to
[__] do it all right and I'm and this
is a warning
[Laughter]
it's a warning I'm going to do it and
I'm going to [__] up so you know if you
want a story I'll [__] do it cuz it's
fun as hell to me and it's weird I don't
feel any pressure whatsoever
because I'm a comedian what's the
pressure he's going to sit down and play
drums he's going to stink of course he
is everybody already knows it so it's
fine um plus everybody just looks the
singer anyways but it's uh it's a lot of
fun and I've been uh getting psycho back
into lessons and um I told you I've been
taking um I've been taking some lessons
um do you remember a long time ago when
I I watched that Mars Volta video and uh
I was talking about their drummer who
was Dave elich at the time I was going
holy [__] look at this this guy's
[__] unbelievable blah blah blah well
from doing that he must have heard the
clip he reached out to me on Twitter and
lo and behold he lives in LA and every
once in a while I go by and I take a
lesson with the guy and uh he's a
[__] unbelievable teacher and he's
been teaching me techniques so my you
know I'm one of those guys I grab the
drumsticks the same way like a toddler
would would just my meaty [__] fist
just right over both of them and it was
causing my arms to be doing all the work
and my forearm if any drummers are
listening to this if you have like that
[__] you know that pain in your
forearm and all that you know that's I
was kind of going through that [__] and
he is teaching me this technique where
you're letting the stick do the work and
it's holding it in this particular way
that do does not seem [__] natural at
all and um it has been a [__]
but you know incrementally I've been
it's gradually working its way into my
playing and
uh it's been it's totally been worth it
and we've been going through this jazz
book and um like most students like I
work on something for 3 seconds and then
want to go on to the next thing so I can
have that sense of accomplishment and
just get through a whole [__] page
and uh and I was moving ahead and every
time I'd go to the lesson I would still
not have the the first thing
down and I've been taking lessons you
know on and off since the summer I mean
I get busy and I can't go for like a
month or something but um I'm still on
that first page and it finally dawned on
me in the past week to to be like dude
just work on this one [__] thing and
[__] everything else and I just sort of
sat down 15 minutes a day just working
on this thing
um you know making little bit of
improvement and then being [__] and
having to start over and blah blah blah
blah and all that [__] and um I actually
had a great lesson this week where I
think he actually was saying that I was
I was finally starting to improve which
made my [__] week so
anyways
um I don't know where the [__] I'm going
with this I'm rambling all over the
place what are we up to here 45 minutes
Jesus Christ Bill can we [__] get on
with this here um oh by the way somebody
told me to watch the show top boy toop
Boy on
Netflix and uh I went on Netflix for
life I can I can figure out how to
search when I'm on the internet I can't
[__] do it when I'm on the TV I don't
how do you search when you're on the TV
if anybody knows I would really
appreciate it but anyways I'm going to
be
um I'm going to be uh playing out again
this week uh I'm doing that bonso bash
thing I'm hosting the bonso bash
co-hosting it I don't even know who I'm
co-hosting with it's going to be in
Anaheim this Friday night and um uh
Brian tish's wonderful event where all
these drummers that I grew up watching
sit down and play lead Zeppelin songs
which is going to be the [__] I'm going
to get to host it and uh with somebody
else it's going to be [__] awesome so
and I will be sitting in for one
song once again risking total
humiliation which you know I'll probably
make an ass to myself who gives a [__]
right um but anyways
uh oh I know what I wanted to talk
about [__] the Arizona Cardinals
Packers game I started to talk about it
and uh you know you would think last
week after watching that dude on the
Bengals intercept the ball and then
[__] walk into the locker room like
well I guess that's that
right you think that these these damn
kids today they'd learned
something Patrick Peterson who I [__]
love LSU kid right incomplete fourth
down that ought to [__] do it two and
a half minutes left this guy's walking
down the sideline waving to the crowd
doing damn near blowing kisses to the
crowd like it's over when he's playing
the Packers in every and [__]
Rogers [__] hilarious two and a half
minutes of football left and he's
walking around doing that and what
happened 2 minutes and 25 football
seconds later he gets beat on a jump
ball in the [__] End Zone on a Hail
Mary to send it into
overtime
um [__]
unbelievable how many times is somebody
going to [__] do that how many times
are you going to run down the field you
got the football you're not past the
goal line you already start holding it
out and Don baby slaps it out of your
hand or you [__] you know you you
spike it over you the the you you know
over your back you know that one where
you throw it down over your shoulder and
you you get big toes Across The End Zone
but the ball isn't how many [__]
times you going to see people do that I
just don't understand why I don't get it
so anyways let's plow ahead here
uh all right here's some the questions
are are the letters for this week all
right pasta Bill if you want to get good
at making pasta of course I do begin
with uh
janiro Caldo videos on food tube all
right I don't know if I said probably
didn't say it right it's g n a r r o and
then the last name is c o n t a l d o s
no d o apostrophe yes
canalo uh the guy taught me so much I
even wished him a happy birthday
uh also pay attention to sorts of flour
you're using cheers to you in your
Mondays yeah what's going some people
use flour some people use that semolina
some people use a mixture of both I tell
I I like doing it I think it goes back
to when I was a kid I was one those kids
like playing in mud puddles you know
what I mean so it was
uh there's just something about that I
think that's why like I I like making
like like pie crust and [__] like that
it's just a big goo we [__] mess it's
fun um but I'll definitely uh I'll check
that out if I can get online here all
right cooking Asian
food all right Bill how are you you
freckled [__] Jesus Jesus no happy New
Year um huge fan from Belgium here nice
bedum and Belgium ACDC flick of the
switch album how many [__] balls you
GNA drop on Payton here this could be
his last game ever what are you doing
Jesus Christ and when did shoulder pads
get so small ever see shoulder pads on
people in the [__] the shoulder pads
were so big the shirt didn't even cover
your belly used to run around with half
shirts on by the way can grun pull his
pants up or get a longer [__]
Jersey he's starting to look like a
waitress at
Hooters all right uh huge fan from
Belgium here um I'm sh saying he's
showing his mid drift that's probably
the wrong
wrong reference who knows you know the
little ass country that people know uh
about because of Austin
Powers Oh I thought I I knew them from
uh I thought isn't that's not Brussels
the muscles from Brussels that was the
guy who used to who's the guy used to do
the
splits the [__] is the guy's
name he wasn't I must break you he
wasn't Steven
Sagal was the other guy from Blood Sport
I gives a [__]
Belgium yeah Luxembourg and Belgium
right right there uh tucked in there
right there uh Battle of the Bulch right
there near France and uh Germany my
nuts in between Amsterdam in uh [__]
Denmark there Copenhagen yeah you're
tucked right there staring at the
[__] uh bad teeth of the English
aren't you looking across the
channel Maybe not maybe if I had a map I
could find it you know all right loved
after effers for family please come to
our our Freckle of a country uh dude I'm
definitely going to go there I'm
definitely going to go there without a
[__] doubt I'm uh I'm we're waiting
to hear about the second season for
effers for family the pitch went [__]
great uh went out of there we were all
excited I got a great feeling about it
and I'm going to let you guys know as
soon as I find out
um I but I got a good feeling about it
so uh and I'm definitely going to do a
European tour I did Australia and Asia
last year so this time it's time to head
the other way I'm going to do uh Europe
this time and I want to hit all the
countries I've been to I'd like to add a
few more and I also want to do a little
bit of Eastern Europe but uh if we do
get a second season I don't know how
many episodes that would be I think it'd
be at least 10 and then you know we got
to sit down and write them and uh if we
want to make it as good as the first
season you know and even better which of
course we do it's going to take a lot of
time so I got to kind of figure out you
know uh once they give us the y or on
that but like I said I got a really
really really Positive Vibes uh a lot of
laughs in the room and um which is
always good so anyways he said the guy
says anyway I've heard you talking about
cooking more Asian
food oh wait this is a different one um
oh it's the same guy sorry any this is
the same guy from uh Belgium he goes
anyways I've heard you talking about
wanting to cook more Asian food on your
podcast since I love cooking as well
please allow me to recommend you some
Korean Cuisine has a lot of spicy food
oh yeah kimchi and all that
stuff
um yeah I've been to those Korean
barbecue and all that stuff I I I I love
all of that stuff but to it's just so
different from the stuff here I'm really
intimidated um about cooking it uh which
is so stupid you
know if I'm I'm afraid of it I should
just just sit down and be like okay
let's start with something easy how do
you make the sticky rice
you know if you could just make sticky
rice alone that's the [__] right that's
the best [__] rice there is I don't
to hear anybody tell me it's not [__]
healthy I don't give a [__] you know
it's [__]
delicious um Korean cuisine has a lot of
spicy food which is great for losing
weight since you tend to
be full more quickly and drink more
water plus a lot of other health
benefits if you are interested please
check
out uh I can't it's m a n g c on YouTube
oh I gotta do
this I oh I guess this is a lady uh
she's a Korean housewife who is funny as
hell and
learns uh teaches you you said learns
you how to cook it's teaches teaches you
how to cook great traditional and
overall easy recipes now you got to
teach me some Belgian words I gave you
one there huh uh recommendations are uh
Belgium words Belgium uh rep
recommendations are spicy pork stir fry
Jing sing
chicken I don't know how to say this
it's j a j a m e o n g jamang that
sounds like an annoying character in
[__] Star Wars which is black bean
sauce
noodles some other [__] that I can't say
Korean barbecue which I bet you've had
before yeah I have what is that the
hacky American thing I've had Korean
food I went to Korean barbecue I
literally just said that Japanese
Cuisine is mostly salty
sweet and
Umami what does umami mean there's that
Umami Burger better that flavors lots of
vegetables no butter soy sauce which is
amazing for you and Rich and Rich taste
yeah I got to tell you man people when I
went over to Asia man they were [__]
in shape people are just in shape over
there you
know I bet if you're fat in Asia they
just man look at that rich [__]
he must be traveling he's got enough
money to get to an
Applebees [__] a uh ah I'm too tired
I didn't want to say Applebees Applebees
is not a fattening place is it what's a
good Jesus bill just wrap up the podcast
okay if I'm going to be this off right
now what the [__] going to happen when
I go to do my shows tonight all right
now Chinese food I don't know a lot
about uh cool to know is that Chinese
food in the states and Europe is not
actual Chinese food no it isn't that's
their surreptitious way of trying to
[__] kill us that's what they're
trying to do they know we have the bomb
right they they they they China is
attacking us on two levels right now
giving us food that's going to give us a
heart attack and they're going to [__]
with our economy somehow somehow we're
tied in with them and they're going to
pull the [__] rug out anyways he said
it's modified for our taste buds but I'm
guessing they have amazing stuff too
yeah I would think I would think so
um the [__] am I getting the hiccups
here uh Thai in Vietnamese food is
mostly spring rolls Jesus Christ you're
going going through the whole continent
here um let me get some
water ah [__] completely missed the
glass [__] bad angle here um lastly
okay no Tha vietamese mostly spring rast
spicy curry I love how a guy from
[__] Belgium is telling me about
Asian food are you at least Asian
lots of coriander which I personally
detest because it tasted of dishwasher
product dishwasher product lastly if you
really want to go hardcore try out North
Korean food it's basically starving
yourself you'll be able to see your
Ginger pube ding-dong without a mirror
again in no time pretty edgy huh yes
you're making fun of the fact that
they're under a dictator that doesn't
feed them very edgy very edgy uh hope
this helped go [__] yourself lots of
love for Nia and oh Cleo
um oh [__] I guess I'll give that you
know I love how Asia stops with people
that we can you know it doesn't go into
India that's also Asia right isn't the
Middle East isn't that also Asia
Russia you know anyway sign that guy in
[__] Forest Gump all right hey Billy
Bean uh been a fan of the podcast for a
while now yada yada I need some advice
or just a fresh perspective on what to
do I'm 23 ah you're in the prime of your
life dropped out of high school like a
[__] at 17 got my GED when I was 19
ah you're back in the game you're back
in the game and it decided to start
becoming a productive member of society
everything was going good paycheck
meant uh the dating Pool opened up tried
a few jobs Etc but now I'm 23 I quit my
job to go to to go to school for
advertising slart at an artsy college
should probably mention the the only
thing I'm truly good at is Art mainly
pen and ink stuff well dude that's a
great thing and you can make a ton of
[__] money doing that it's just that
schools generally speaking are not
geared towards that um so yeah you were
[__] bored and then you took [__]
that you weren't good at made you feel
like an [__] you [__] drop out you
party for a few years
right bangged a couple of who is and now
you're coming back dude you're fine
you're 23 dude you're fine
uh that was 8 months ago I missed the
sign I missed the sign up date and just
lacked the general knowledge SLS support
on going about it I spent six months
grinding the living [__] out of drawing
trying to achieve something I might be
able to take some pride in didn't work I
was just going to say you're being too
hard on yourself your next line is I'm
hard on myself to the point where I'm
thinking I'll never be handed a metal as
the greatest that ever [__] lived so
why
bother
ah Jesus
dude well listen Richard prior is the
greatest of all time and I'll never come
close to that guy that that's not going
to stop me you just try to see how close
you can come some people you can't pass
and that's all right you know you just
try to come as close to him try to just
like try to go as high up the alltime
ladder as you possibly can and who knows
if you keep pushing
yourself listen you
you don't know what your limits are
until you keep [__] throwing yourself
out there especially if you're hard on
yourself you're probably being way
you're way better than you think you are
you're going to be fine all right you
you're depressing me here anyways I've
since quit drawing and now do nothing
but troll around dating sites all day
and hooking up with semi-decent looking
women women as a way to stay positive
and cure boredom I'm not lazy I've done
primarily uh manual labor jobs and know
I have the back for it but Jesus Christ
I can't force myself to pull the trigger
on anything because I can't be the top
of the crop or the very goddamn best I
won't be fulfilled I've been standing at
a crossroad with my dick in my hand for
nearly a year any sort of advice be
[__] amazing don't hold back if you
think I need to be ripped a new one I
can handle it thanks go [__] yourself
yeah dude you've got yourself into a
completely paralyzed State here be it's
like you got it you just bought a guitar
and because you're not Jimmy Hendrick
within the first two weeks you're going
to [__] quit all right if Jimmy
Hendrick did that he wouldn't be Jimmy
Hendricks all
right all right look
just if you whatever you like to do in
life just go out and do it all right and
enjoy it and don't put that level of
pressure on
yourself like what was was your dad like
the great Santini or something I'm
trying to figure out why you like this
but like
um the reason why you can't pull the
trigger on on anything else in life is
because you actually have a strong I
think you have a strong sense on what
makes you happy and what you want to
do all right and you know that despite
the fact that you're being totally
negative about your drawing you know
that that's what you want to do and you
have such a passion for it that you're
that hard on yourself and then also it's
preventing you from getting a job at the
[__] Costco whatever the goddamn
place you're going to end up [__]
working at
um I would I don't know if I was you I
would continue drawing I'd get into
computers and all that there's all kinds
of stuff I've seen people do drawings on
computers and they they turn that into
building websites which helps to pay for
their their studio and the [__] that
they really want to do there's there's
tons of money to make in the Arts don't
don't let anybody ever [__] tell you
that there isn't dude just helping
people make it in show
business all right there's PE people who
get head shots give acting classes and
all that just doing that [__] people
make a small [__] fortune so if
you're actually a talented artist you
can
actually you're going to be fine um you
just have to stop beating the [__] out
of yourself all right so uh just pay
attention to that voice in your head
when it tells you you can't do something
just tell it to shut the [__] up
basically even if you have to say it out
loud you know just make sure you're not
looking at somebody you care about as
they're telling you a story when you
thinking those thoughts just you know
maybe maybe say it in your brain first
all right
okay advice no one to relate to Jesus
these are [__] gloomy this
week all right advice no one to relate
to causing Lon
loneliness all right hey Billy bats love
the podcast you stand up efforts for
family uh they all put a smile on my
face well that's great okay I'm I'm
sensing that all of a sudden now the
smile's going to go away I hope you read
this
because my problem is I have no one to
relate to and I fear I might as well
read this here I hope you read this
because I've been doing everything
positive but I just can't seem to get my
life where I want it to be it's a bit of
a long road so please bear with me oh
[__] is this a long
email dude you know I can't read out
loud all right my problem is I have no
one to relate to and I fear I might be
Co this might be causing
me to be lonely in life I fear that if I
continue the way I'm going I may never
get over it I'm in my last semester of
college in an engineering program and
have made almost no friends throughout
my entire stay at College I am at the
top of my classes and I'm lining up jobs
at Big tech companies now you're
probably imagining some point deer with
the pocketer pocket protector and all
that actually I was that's exactly that
was the picture you were painting sir uh
quite the opposite actually I've been
working out for a few years now and I
have one and I am one of the jacked
people in my classes all right so now
I'm picturing is that dude an American
Psycho highly achieving totally shredded
cannot relate to human beings um I dress
well eat healthy please tell me you
don't listen to hu uh Huey Lewis in the
news
um and always make
sure to keep myself clean I feel like I
might alienate my classmates from
interacting with me they probably think
I'm just a jock in their class where
it's quite the opposite I'm into gaming
chess and all of that dude you're like a
[__] uh renaissance man here so I
figure I might try to interact with the
opposite crowd the non- geeky people I
know a way to meet people is to get out
there and do something I I like doing
playing some sport or joining a club or
volunteering the problem is with my
program and my work I have little time
to be doing much else the only free time
I have is Friday or Saturday nights that
I spend by myself playing video games or
playing guitar because I have nothing
else to do well you could go out those
nights all right it wasn't always this
way this is like a movie when I was in
high school my life was completely the
opposite I didn't work out eat healthy
work hard or nothing but I always found
ways to make new friends make people
laugh and start conversations now that
I'm doing everything right it seems my
only problem is social a Jesus Christ
dude so you know what you're doing
you're just too busy I fear once I
graduate college things will only get
worse I lost all of my f my family apart
from my older brother who is in another
country so once I graduate college I'll
truly be alone no one to grab a beer
with no one to help me move or anything
help me move or anything despite all
this I try to be positive and thankful
what I have and what I have accomplished
sorry for the long email and go [__]
yourself yeah dude you just look you
already know how to make friends I would
you need to make time to do
it
um playing video games by yourself is
very
antisocial uh playing guitar is always
cool that's fun why don't you play
guitar with somebody else find somebody
who plays drums and play bass get
together do some covers you know Jam
[__] around you know drink some beers
invite some ladies over you every week
you just add some more [__]
right you know start taking bets open
your own [__] uh draft Kinks You know
maybe start selling Coke just keep
expanding your ring of uh social
interaction I'm obviously [__] with
you but no I would uh there's a bunch of
people that are into video games why
don't you find somebody that you can
play against can you do that anymore do
kids do that or do you have to go online
to do
it you
know is that like corny now does two
people not sit next to each other with
an Atari with the joystick and the one
red button is are we past that I don't
[__] know but it seems like you know
how to do that stuff you just got busy
and uh with all your achievement you you
know sometimes you know when you go
after a goal some things suffer all
right I've talked about this numerous
times when I was on
um you know when I was 36 years old I
was I was [__] living alone in a
studio apartment that they called the
one bedroom sleeping on a futon I
remember days just going by going what
the [__] have I done the only thing I've
worked on is trying to become a comedian
everything else is at the starting line
and uh over the next 10 years I just
worked on some [__] like that
so that's all you need to do all right
Jesus Christ I'm starting to feel like
Dr Phil here um all right what do we got
here third and goal Broncos have the
ball with three minutes left and I'm
doing a [__] podcast touchdown
Broncos all right all right Broncos now
here you go celebrating and act like a
bunch of [__] idiots when Ben
rothberger has three minutes
left this one is not over all right so
what does this do this puts them up by
five I hey people in the crowd holding
up two fingers like the crowd's going to
look at them oh yeah yeah we should go
for two shouldn't we we shouldn't just
be up by six thank you thank you you in
the [__] uh mezzanine level
ah
[__] are we going to have to go to
Denver is this going to be one
more one more Brady either way this is
going to be great either this you get to
see Brady versus uh pton Manning one
more
time I'm assuming he's retiring which is
stupid or you get to see another
Patriots uh Steelers matchup with
[__] Big Ben Big Ben Not Afraid of
Anything Big Ben both great teams all
right that's the podcast for this week I
apologize that my head was kind of all
over the place I don't know what flying
and going to the [__] airport does to
me
um but uh it makes me even more [__]
scatterbrain so anyways go [__]
yourselves and I will talk to you on
Thursday okay all
[Music]
right hey what's up everybody and
welcome back to the number one sports
show I'm doing my best Paul
verie uh the anything better podcast
with me Bill Burr Jake The Snake Andrew
tholus and
unfortunately Paul verie has morning
sickness no uh from all those years of
the Nicks [__] them no uh Paul verie
is sick this week uh whatever I don't
know what if he had what I had had it a
few weeks ago about a month ago this
stomach flu that was just uh it was epic
um anyway but um he's not going to be
here this week so you're gonna have to
deal with me I'll try to talk to the
other people as much as possible so
you're not annoyed uh anyways let's talk
about bet GM with the best betting lines
in the business bet $5 you get 158 bucks
instantly there's a [__] algorithm
why not 155 or 160 158 bucks instantly
place your first bet MGM Sportsbook
wager through bmgm Sportsbook mobile
application for at least five bucks and
you will receive
158 thread in the needle instantly in
additional winnings regardless of your
Wagers outcome uh how to get this
offered what you have to do is download
the bmgm Sportsbook app on a on iOS or
Android uh or visit betmgm.com sign up
and deposit at least $5 into your newly
credited account place a wager in the
amount of at least five bucks at
standard odds price once you have placed
a bet you will receive
158 not 57 not 59
$158 in bonus bets regardless of the
outcome of your
wager all right let's get to it here um
I'm here with Jake The Snake and Andrew
Themis all right here we go before we
get started dude I just had the dumbest
[__] argument with my beautiful
wife dude I swear to to God she knows
every single restaurant every coffee
shop she knows every [__] it's
literally there's no way to surprise her
she goes online oh I went online and I
looked at the menu like she there's
always something of I've already been
here so for [__] 20 years I've been
trying to surprise
her all right so I find this [__]
coffee shop right super like cute place
where you can bring your your wife or
your girlfriend you know they got ke and
all those stupid little [__] muffins
and a bunch of different drinks it's a
nice place it's little upstairs thing
right so I tell her you know drop the
kids off at school I tell her okay I'm
going to take you to this coffee shop
and the whole way over she's like you
going here are we going this place and
then it's just like will you just will
you stop it just let me [__] do this
so we pull into the place and I'm like
wincing knowing somehow she's already
been here with the girlfriend or they
had a mommy meeting there or something
and I pull in she's like what is this
place I didn't know about this place and
I'm like yes [__] did it okay first
thing we do we get out of the car and
they have like a front door but you
can't go in it you got to go in the side
door and the first thing walk she's like
honey honey I think we're supposed to I
think we're she's already telling me how
to go into the [__] place that I've
already been to and I'm like no you got
to go around the side I just shoot her a
look and she starts
laughing she starts laughing cuz this is
what she does so we go in there and
she's like oh my
God like exactly what I wanted this
place is so cute and all of this
[__] and then you know what you know
what Jake and Andrew she finds out the
name of the place you know Milla cuties
or whatever she's like Milla cuties
Milla cuties Mill wait a minute is this
the Milla cies from down and I'm go a
[__] and then she goes up there and has
to ask him and then she comes back it is
it is it is they just
moved I was so [__] like just
heartbroken you're gonna need just like
there you go all right so you haven't
been here but you've been here and she
just and then all of a sudden I was
being a
dick and she said what I'm just curious
I'm just curious no it's just dude 20
years any gift I give her
I know what this is I know what this is
can you imagine if I did that it's a
cigar holder they would [__] cry
you're going to need to like sketch
literally fing cry she does it to me
every it's it's literally Charlie Brown
trying to kick the [__] football and
I just sent to it today I go I am
[__] done I'm taking you to
McDonald's from here on out you want to
go to a [__] place you pick the place
where you already know you've already
been there you already know the [__]
menu I am done I am done and then you
know the whole re me is she's like like
I'm the
dick you're need to create business from
scratch like start a business from
scratch so it's like one of those like
you know shows where they surprise
people some douche on Instagram would be
like what is this and they would film it
and she would somehow see
[Music]
it yeah yeah you know what the greatest
part about all of this at the end of all
of this I'm gonna have to
apologize
I'm sorry I didn't realize you know
everything I I should have I should have
realized
that oh my God it's amazing how they
know everything but you know it's just
like can you apply that to picking these
[__] playoff games for this [__]
week I would love it although I think I
think we did pretty good last week yeah
hit the Monday night special we hit the
Monday night special Paul bery from
Beyond the PUK grave is very excited for
all of you guys we did we hit the we hit
the Monday night special it's our second
one this year um even with all the new
uh you know
restrictions I'm not going to keep using
that as an excuse let's just talk about
last week's playoffs um I don't know I
didn't see anything
uh the Texans just beating the [__] out
of the
Browns um I don't know what to do with
that game Jake what do I do with that do
I just sit there and say the Browns were
just not up for the [__] challenge or
am I really you know cuz this the Trap
game I feel like this week is the way
the Texans played last week and for some
reason are nine and a half Point
underdogs they're just dangling that
carrot come on man jump on the line and
I'm supposed to be like dude they
[__] totally dominated the Cleveland
Browns and now they're getting nine and
a half dude it's a [__] luck I don't
like that I completely agree and also
the FL I think Flack out kind of just
like the clock ran out he threw two pick
sixes in the second half back to back
and the game kind of just got out of
hand um but Houston you know St is um St
is super impressive as well so there I
like about Houston did they cover nine
and a half though it's a big number they
could easily back door cover it like
it's telling Andrew but um oh God I
think I haven't had a back door cover
this whole [__] year if I take the
underdog they just lose if I take the
favorite you know sometimes I win but
that back door cover I mean I don't know
maybe I uh maybe I haven't been paying
attention but I I get bit a lot by that
but let's talk about all these games
here before we uh pick um the [__]
Eagles what yeah what you think of
Dallas getting blown out as well um did
they they kind of got blown out in the
first half and then played with them for
the rest of the game and I feel like
that's what nobody's talking about for
as much as they got blown out they let
up 400 yards passing and everybody's
trying to tell me that was garbage time
I I don't think the third quarter the
end of the second quarter into of the
third quarter was garbage time I'll give
you some of the fourth quarter where
they probably started pulling some
people out but like at the end of the
day they were up 27 to nothing they only
won by 16 they let up 400 [__]
yards
um you know I I am a big fan of Jordan
love big fan of their offense and all of
that type of stuff but that secondary I
was I wasn't too impressed with did they
just decide to stop trying we're up 27
we can chill like uh so I don't I don't
find that victory over Dallas as imp as
impressive like I don't look at them
like you
know they're G to go in and be these
World beaters and they're getting nine
and a half against the 49ers I [__]
hate this week then you had the Eagles
dude mercifully ripping the band off
Band-Aid off and just getting out of the
playoffs then I love how they like that
Nick s serani is on the [__] hot seat
it's like they took his offensive and
defensive coordinator this is what
happens when you go to a Super Bowl
um I still believe in that guy and he's
a fun guy to
have just emotionally volatile it was
just like oh my God people having a ball
with him seeya all that [__] he doing
and then like people had the meme like
am I getting fired this week and they
had the that stupid nod that he did when
he does that nod when I don't like about
the ND is he looks
dumb it's so crazy I know he isn't I
don't I don't think it's
uh I mean what do you think happened
down there somebody must have gotten
hurt I don't know somebody's trying to
say oh you played they lost to somebody
and they tried to say that they exposed
him I love when they say that they
expose like we my team figured you out
like the 49ers or something um I don't
know but I I don't I don't think that
they're going to they're going to
they're going to get rid of that guy uh
although I will say next year he does
need to
win early and
often and uh I almost think he needs to
win two playoff games next year how
brutal a job is that right that's what I
was gonna say it's not as hard as trying
to surprise my wife with a new [__]
restaurant but I mean it's it's
definitely up
there I mean he made the Super Bowl and
he still won 11 games this year it's not
like he they didn't have a decent season
you know until the end there but they
still beat the Chiefs and the Dolphins
and the Cowboys they you know all
right they did but then they they just
uh something happened I think Jaylen
Herz was hurt they didn't have their
number one receiver I think like there
was something beyond that and then
everybody just looks at I just love how
every like serani was on inside the NFL
and they were just talking about him
like dude like you know you're you're
the new [__] genius like what are you
doing here and then like a month later
it's like Nikki's on the hot
seat it's so quick to fire these guys
it's crazy I I can't imagine how well
what do you think about the Cowboys are
going to stick with Mike mccy that's
crazy I was gonna ask you absolutely
crazy that's crazy um I don't think
Jerry Jones is a good owner I just think
he's an owner with a lot of money he's
got a lot of money and he and he and he
built this big you know he teachs he
treats the Dallas Cowboy fans like his
side piece like how the those those
French Kings back in the day they'd have
like a side piece and they'd literally
build a castle for just to shut her up I
feel like that's what he did with that
Stadium like look how big it is it's the
biggest goddamn bathroom in all football
we got the biggest [__] TV we got the
biggest Dome this [__] place is Big
it's bigger than anybody's [__] and then
then meanwhile the Cowboys don't win
anything
and they but they can be proud of their
Stadium or something like I I I don't
think
uh I remember I took a tour of it and
they said how Jerry had an Express
Elevator from his suite to get down to
the field as soon as possible because he
wants to be like all up in it when they
win he has like that steinbrener
thing like I I just I never liked owners
like that where like when the team's
losing like they they they publicly have
to make issue with
statement like what did Jerry say after
that loss that was
informative that disappointing loss he
had to he had to go on camera inform all
all of us that he was
indeed uh upset with that
disappointed it's like thanks Jerry I
didn't think you were [__] doing
cartwheels
um I don't know uh I look at like
trashing coaches like trashing other
comedians publicly it's just not
something I would do you know what I
mean so it's a brutal job it's a tough
[__]
job
um I don't know I mean when you when you
lose when you're down 27 to nothing all
right and some of the sloppy tackling
and [__] like that it's like is Mike
McCarthy supposed to put a [__]
helmet on too like I don't know I don't
know I was surprised I thought that they
were going to
uh you know make a move so uh I would
have loved to have been in Dallas when
they said that they were keeping him and
just put on Sports Talk
Radio just to hear all these
people I mean what the [__] are we
doing I mean they spent a lot of time
hating him as the coach of the Packers
not that they were like you know I mean
first stretch obviously they were
winning most of the games but but yeah
like I mean then then they're like all
right fine we'll get them maybe here's
where it'll work and then they're like
oh look he's doing what he did with the
Packers so that's why there's very
probably didn't he coach one with Aaron
and get one didn't he get one the one
yeah did but that was how many people
get that I know I know that was one I
know over here yeah
um uh yeah I was surprised at that I
wasn't surprised that the Eagles are
sticking with siriani that would have
been stupid to fire him I agree um but
on I really feel like the the offseason
chatter is going to be all of these
coaches um yeah that was a big deal all
the people would have been great for the
Cowboys on paper you know they have a
good defense and stuff like that I mean
obviously it never work with Jerry Jones
but like if he took that out of the
equation that would have been the
perfect place for him but you know I
think Jerry Jones wants a coach he can
control to your point yeah and when is
he gonna let go of that yeah he [__]
got he [__] it up with Jimmy Johnson
when did Al Davis get rid of that you
die right
well Al Davis I don't I don't think he
was overly uh yeah but he was another
guy different he was
different yeah he had well he he was
like the Flyers he had this formula and
it worked and then he just never wavered
from it even when it wasn't Philadelphia
Flyers like we beat the [__] out of the
whole league and won two in a row let's
keep doing they did that for like 40
years and like all right maybe it's time
to switch it of let's try to get some uh
goal scorers in here maybe try to do a
little festing um
[Music]
uh oh my God I just
got text message for my
wife I'll smooth that over guys I will
smooth that over until she sees this
podcast whatever just frustration okay
here we go let's get into these games
gentlemen
um Texans this is so weird without Paul
verie this is like you know the starting
quarterback is like down and I'm I'm
coming in off the bench uh Texans plus 9
a half at the Ravens minus n and a half
the obvious pick here is the way that
the Texans absolutely dominated last
week and the way that they've played all
year is to take nine and a half points
but I just feel like I don't know it's
like does Vegas know something or is
just this just a way to get money on
both sides of the ball because
everyone's going to take the Ravens
um I think I me Ravens oh sorry go ahead
Jake this is a Point Flip yeah I just
think everyone's gonna take Texans
actually to your point you talked about
it earlier everyone's gonna be all
excited about strout and how they blew
out Cleveland they think oh this will be
a good game but you know I I think um
yeah I just feel like that are they
still too young or whatever is this
going to happen with the experience
everybody's healthy on the
Ravens yeah everybody's health healthy
they thought they were going to get
somebody back but but he's not coming
back but they haven't had him all year
um but for the most part all the teams
are healthy the only team with injury
concerns we'll talk about it later is
the is the bills all right then I'm
gonna I'm gonna take the Ravens I'm not
I'm not that feels like a sucker bet to
take the Texans plus n and a half and
also feels stupid to be laying nine and
a half in the [__] playoffs but uh
I'm gonna take the Ravens I'm going with
Ravens on that and we we have Paul V's
picks right who did Paul take Paul took
the
he did all right and you know look who's
better picking games Paul or me we
both um all right
Packers plus n and a half at the 49ers
minus n and a half Jesus Christ nine and
a
half
um I just feel like this is going to be
big boy football they're not ready for
it yet 49ers have too many weapons I
know last week uh was an impressive win
but I just feel like the Dallas Cowboys
you
know their problem is
ownership and the level of control that
he wants and then what he does to
whoever whoever is trying to coach his
team so I I think the 49ers cover nine
and a half Jesus Christ I'm laying 19
points after two
games what did ver take he took the
Packers he he said that wow he really
believes in these people
huh I I don't know what the difference
like if if it was Packers seven and a
half like would I mean people still
would take I don't know yeah it's a
weird number I don't know what they're
trying to do if they're trying to get
people off the Packers or on the Packers
it's so this is what's happening Paul is
basically believing what he saw last
week and I am not cuz what I saw last
week I didn't see anybody that I thought
was going to make it like without a
doubt they're going to the Super Bowl
granted I didn't watch that stupid uh
how funny was the way they they sold
that that uh pay-per-view playoff this
one of my favorite thing become part of
History I was joking on Monday morning
Paul I'll never forget where I
was I ordered that playoff game that was
always free dude they they're gonna work
their way to a pay-per-view Super Bowl
that's what they they want the
advertising money or the licensing and
then they want everyone at home what if
everyone it's like they all bought
tickets we'll charge five bucks six
bucks a billion people watch even if
there's four people per household we're
still going to clear an extra billion
dollars and then imagine how big our
yachts and whes and cocaine could be
it's so [__] gross I will slowly back
away you know what I'll do if if they do
that I'm just going to wait 10 14 days
and I'll watch the Super Super Bowl for
free on uh on the [__] NFL Network
they'll end up puking it back out the
other side they won't care um all right
Baker Mayfield just a good old boy uh
laying oh getting six and a half at the
Lions minus 6 and a half I'm telling you
I'm Billy
favorites I'm Billy favites this week
I'm I'm leaning towards the lines
somebody somebody knock me off this
you're going away from your your guy
Baker I don't think so so close I know I
know you know yeah [__] that you're
right where's my sense of
adventure I feel like I'm gonna be 0 and
three with this pick but I'm gonna
go no I was saying to Jake before we
started I was like well an underdog is
gonna win I mean maybe likely right and
it's like all right well who's who's it
gonna be and that's why I a great call
that's a great call somebody's gonna
somebody it's not gonna be all favorites
most likely and I don't look at the
Chiefs and bills even at two and a half
like that that's that's a pick them I'm
going to yeah that's a good point oh I
can be swayed in two seconds win Bill
somebody's got a win six and a half six
and a half I'll I'll I'll I'll take some
points the Buccaneers they could cover
that number I think you know how they
say the Eagles got exposed I feel like
I'm getting exposed without having Paul
verzy here who did Paul take listen
Paul's not seeing that the way you're
seeing it he took the
lion this is amazing oh my god dude
right now we're both well I can't say
three and 0 0 and three they're uh yeah
whatever we have the exact opposer two
one and two two and one however this is
going to work out all right then the
final one the Monday night game the
Chiefs verse the
bills in
Buffalo the Buffalo Bills for the love
of [__]
god are they
finally cuz I was rooting for him this
year and then once they started [__]
the bed I was just like oh this is what
it feels like to be a Bills fan I've
been here before back in the day this is
the way it used to be being a Patriots
fan well kind of is now again um I don't
need this [__] so I kind of like backed
off like it was just they were just
playing annoying
football
um Jake who do you have you know you
know what dude you know what I I love
the bills and I want them to win but
this is about
money okay and until the [__] bills
prove their entire history wrong I mean
I have to go with the Chiefs I have to
go with Patrick
Mahomes um how almost said Andre Reid
Andy Reid and and and Kelsey and those
guys I
just listen who gives a [__] this is the
deal my money I'm going to bet the
Chiefs my hat I'm rooting for the bills
so I'm going with the Chiefs Plus two
and a
half Paul ver Paul ver what do you take
what's uh ver actually picked the bills
he
did WOW head tohe on every game has that
ever happened before I don't think so
yeah this is good though so this is good
replacing Paul
verie this is gonna be like a
definitive like unless you know what
sucks if we both go two and two I want
this is what I want I want a 4-0 or 0
and4 that's what I want yeah like when
you fill out those surveys they want
that strongly disagree strongly agree
you're looking for a very clear like
this is a this is going to be this is
literally like blue State Red State how
much differently they they what they
they think
um okay the Lea it's crazy good no no
I'm I'm good so let's let's do okay the
Monday night special I need Paul verie
on this one because I feel like you know
last week we won because of him he
didn't uh offer up anything on on that
just weekly picks yeah so dude he
offered up his inside since he was
puking through all of this you know when
he told me he goes guys I can't do the
podcast have been puking all night and I
wrote I wrote to
him did you watch the Knicks last night
and even in the Mist this is how di hard
he is even in the midst of being that
sick he still had the energy to text
they've won seven of the last
10 when I read the text I didn't even
know he was puking yet because I thought
it was just Nick's talk I had to scroll
up to realize he even said he puked um
yeah oh yeah no listen if you don't like
Paul Bersy you don't like America or
Sicily or Greece the man the man is just
simply an ambassador of of of positivity
and support that's why this show works
there's a there's the balance I'm the
kudin all right so let's do uh Chief's
bills well I I don't like this because
he picked the bills so I don't know what
he would think about the special but
we're going to have to go with this I
like uh he often goes against his weekly
pick for the Monday night special if if
he feels like it's a good overall play
so on that each week momes and Allen are
both gonna throw one what's the over
under 45 and a half I like the under
because last time they played they had
that circus of a game
um and I just think
everybody's sorry it's supposed to be
cold there it's supposed to be cold in
Buffalo that's all um so that helps
global warming am I right thank you Joe
bid probably still shoveling too um uh
and that kind of sucks they didn't play
the
game how funny would that have been yeah
just just running the ball the whole
time remember those games when they
would just play him and they would throw
the ball and it would just get like it
like like a train came by and hit
it yeah um all right so I got I got Josh
Allen Josh Allen Meers to throw one I
got uh I got Patrick
mahomies to uh to throw
one um and I got the I got the under is
that is that good enough for a special
yeah that
works all right here's my prediction I
go 0 and four but I hit them under night
special I redeemed myself at the last
second
um I love it what happened to me oh
Billy favorites I used to always take PA
I used to beat Paul of course when we
didn't televise this I beat him every
year because Paul just would he didn't
give a [__] what the line was he just
this it's going to be a blood bath and I
used to always take The Underdogs and
they would cover you know I mean I
didn't beat him by a bunch of games but
I would beat him and he goes you always
[__] get me with this and I just
finally told him I was like Paul you got
to
stop jumping on these giant lines this
is how not this is how much he's honed
his game he used to go hard the first
week of college
football you lost all those seniors you
had no idea who anybody was but um I
think he's proven over the years Paul
ver is Mr
October the bookie does not want to pick
up the phone when Paul V's numbers shows
up in October that guy what what was his
record in October dude it was [__]
insane
it's like 14 and two 13 and three or
something you don't have to look the
stat up he crushed it we all know he
crushed it all right well that has
been uh the special not the special this
has been the uh the anything better
podcast for the first time ever Lou
Garrick sits out a game I consider
myself I said it myself the luckiest
Gambler in the world thank you so much
for uh for watching and how about how
about Jake The Snake's playoff beard I
mean he looks like that guy that gamer
that comes in Off the Bench who is this
guy changing the play at the line
stomping his foot like [__] what's
his face there what's a pton Manning
going up top um I'm GNA be we added a
show quick uh promotion here in Phoenix
on February 28th we addited another show
um I'm gonna have a great time out there
maybe go golfing I got a Skins game
coming up guys me and Paul verie versus
Vinnie Mark Vinnie Mark the [__] pool
shark with a golf club in his hand he's
going to try to take us for a bunch of
money so what I'm going to try to do is
get a high handicap and then take
lessons between now and
may try not to putt past the hole in
[__] five putt um anyways I am uh
dude I I hit the clubs all all this week
all right and I got this whole new like
20 [__] minutes and uh it has been
absolutely murdering I've been talking
about the uh the Epstein list and all of
that and I am so excited to get out
there and I'm I'm literally usually when
when a break is coming to an end I get
sad that I have to go out in the road
again and I'm not I'm like I feel like I
took some roids you know like you want
to go run through a [__] wall see how
real this is right capture it one last
time no am I the only guy out there um
all right and then Paul ver is going to
be in point Pleasant New Jersey on
January 26th yep uh he's going to have a
flu stomach too with all this puking man
he's going to he's going to be ready for
the red C
it all right old Paul the puker will be
on next week uh we went exact opposite
exact opposite so there should be a
bunch of people out there either saying
I don't know what the hell I'm talking
about and ver does or vice versa that's
it everybody uh I appreciate you
sticking with us without uh the man
the star of the show the man who beats
the book because he can sleep with his
picks Paul verie that's it everybody
enjoy the playoff football uh I gotta go
apologize to my
wife all right guys I'll see you